well
let me at a high level see if you can
pull this off if i ask you
uh what's the book new right about
it's about a group of people
who are united solely by their
opposition to progressivism
who have little else in common but who
are all
frequently caricatured and dismissed
by the larger establishment media
but you give this kind of story of how
it came to be
sure and to me like we're talking about
trolls
but the internet side of things is quite
interesting
so first of all how does alt-right
connect
so the alt-right is the subset of the
new right
which feels that race not racism is
the most or one of the most important
socio-political issues
are any of those folks like
part of the mainstream or worth paying
attention to
not only by the mainstream the alt-right
yeah by definition they would be part of
the mainstream
they would not be part of that no they
would not i don't know
that any of them well worth is not a
position i'm not able to say worth
i'm i would say that it is of use
to be familiar with their arguments
because to dismiss
any school of thought especially one
that has historically
gained leverage especially one that has
historically gained leverage in very
dark ways especially in america in
europe and other places
just to say oh they're racist i don't
need to think about them
it's it's it doesn't behoove you so what
uh what lessons do we draw from the
the 4chan side of things like the
internet side
of the movement tits or get the out
um can you define every single word hits
our breasts
or get the out that's from 4chan
okay
that's what's uh what's it mean oh
sometimes like a woman will appear in
4chan and they'll just reply tits or get
the out
i'm trying to understand what oh oh
that's a way
i just um very slow oh so that's
okay so that's very disrespectful
towards female
members of the community i don't
understand there's rules to this
community
and one of them is uh we're not very
good with women
is that that's one of those principles
it's a principle we're not going to ever
get laid
that's fundamental principle is there we
are going to get pics
pics sometimes sometimes on the
sometimes like gtfo
gt okay so is there other actual
principles
of so like it's it's
maybe naive perspective is they have
like the darkest aspects of trolling
which is like take nothing serious
make a game out of everything that's not
4chan per se
one of the things that you will learn
4chan which i think is very healthy
is if you have an idiosocratic or unique
worldview or focus on an aspect of
history or culture
you'll be able to find like-minded
people who will engage with you and
discuss it without being
pres promptly dismissive that's an ideal
that they well it's not ideal it's
something that happens a lot now 4chan
is not really
like paul as their board with politics
um but they will
you know get into some like the people
there are much more erudite than you
think
so they do take my my perception was
they take nothing seriously so there's
things that they take seriously like
discussing ideas i'll give you one
example there was a video someone posted
of a girl who put kittens in a bag and
threw in a river
and they found out where she was within
a day and got her like arrested
so yeah they do take some things very
seriously
okay but that's like an extreme that
i mean that's good first of all that's
heartwarming that they wouldn't somehow
turn that into a thing
that feels like more of uh what is it
what's the other one 8chan
8 chance twice as good as 4chan yeah
that's their slogan
but it feels like they're the kind of
community that would take that kitten
situation and make a mockery yeah
they're they're a darker than fortune
yeah yeah
i don't even i'm not allowed to talk
about 16 chan
i'm already overwhelmed clearly uh by
4chan
lingo i'm i have actu i literally wrote
down on my notes
um like in doing research for this
conversation
i learned the word pleb and
i wanted to ask you what does pleb mean
you know what fled means no
i don't wait i saw i mean actually no i
don't
you know what a pleb is i just i don't
know what a flub is
like a plebiscite or plebeian okay but
does it mean something more
sophisticated um no it's a very
unsophisticated mechanism of being
dismissive
of like the regular people yeah or
someone who comes at me
on twitter okay all right so back to
the 4chan alt-right it wasn't the those
are very different concepts
don't don't conflate them but which
internet culture was the alt-right born
out of
uh alright was more born of blogs and
people had different blogs where they
were posting what they call like racial
realism
scientific which is scientific racism
so-called um and
you know breaking down issues from a
racialist perspective so that wasn't
4chan is much more uh dynamic it's a
message board it's
very fluid um so it doesn't lend itself
to these kind of in-depth analysis of
ideas or history
but it spreads them like it they spread
them as memes
yeah and you know but but it's not it's
not an essential mechanism of uh
of the alt-right historical no no no no
no no no so it was both
mostly about blogs okay so what uh
what do you make of the psychology of
this kind of world view
when you have this goes to your
conspiracy theory subject earlier
when you have a little bit of knowledge
about something about history that no
one's talking about
and there's only one group that is
talking about it
and they and you have no alternative
answers
you're going to be drawn to that group
so because issues about
race anti-semitism homophobia are so
taboo in our culture
understandably there's good reasons if
you start putting things like how old
should you be
you have sex with kids and just have
regular conversations eventually some
people are going to start taking some
positions you don't like so some things
have to be sanctified to some extent
they're the only ones talking about it
you're going to be drawn to that
a subculture and where does the
alt-right stand now
i mean i hear that term used so the term
has been weaponized by the corporate
press
for people that they want to read out of
society
so it's used both on individual levels
like people like gavin
mcingus milo yiannopoulos some others
they i mean i think they refer to trump
as alt-right
um and and you know it's become a slur
just like in cell or bot that has become
largely removed from its original
meaning
do you have a sense that there's still a
movement that's all right or like
yeah they call themselves now so okay so
there's something called the dissident
right
and they say we're completely not like
the alt-right because the alt-right's a
b and c
and we're bcd there's a huge overlap
it's very much the same people
um is there intellectuals that still
represent some awesome aspect of the
movement
i mean sure are you tracking this not
not that much anymore
um i think they've they're i don't find
it particularly as
um now that the book's done you know my
i'm looking more into history for my
next book um
you mentioned communism i'm gonna talk a
lot about the cold war
um so this kind of stuff has largely uh
fallen away from my radar to some extent
and they've also been the the it's been
a very effective movement to get them
marginalized and silenced
so they're not as as deep as of a
concern in terms of
concern or not just their impact on
society
you